[Musique]
obama la gamme vds où vous avez vu
quelqu'un tu crois que c'est quoi les
rues king est
salut c'est comme ça partout dans toute
la ville y'a plus personne nulle part
oui monsieur
si longtemps
ford mustang gt500 celle de 1967 elle
permit à la conduite accompagnée
le cas
c'était quoi j'ai pas mais ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on n'est pas seul aux
manettes on va partir à quitter la ville
je vais pas sûr de rebaptiser j'ai
jamais vu un truc pareil brouillard de
plus en plus proche pour passer
ça me rappelle une bd qu'il sait quand
j'étais petit j'avais un perso il
ressemble vachement le maître des
couteaux
on n'est pas ensemble on n'y arrivera
pas
[Musique]